welcome back to Las Vegas now you can go
up the room come through come through
come through this how we do it's live TV
cheap shot is a new showroom downtown
and Mavericks variety show is the star
here to tell us more and give us a taste
of the of the show The the madness I
should say downtown we have the host
this is misbehave and this is Clint the
exotic bird trainer I mean you can be
one too today
I feel like there's a bird on my
shoulder there it is no no I love The
Madness of this thank you so much for
being here tell us more about the show
what can we expect at this show it is we
thought that downtown could really use a
permanent variety yes what we thought
would be great was if we got some
brilliant acts and put them all together
in a beautiful room and that's what
we're doing
talking that's just talking and the
show's fast-paced right it's like
Tick-Tock style right exactly it's like
basically I mean that's my tagline it's
a it's a variety show for tick tock
generation and you've been performing
around town before have you not
misbehaved where else I have I used to
have my um game show on The Strip for
three years at Bally's can someone take
this take this someone take this thing
keep going
yes it used to be at bali's and that was
a super crazy show okay really crazy
show
um and worked a treat and then the
pandemic came along as we know and so
now I'm working with the lovely Ryan
though and calling about with amazing
new venue new showroom finally beautiful
serum we're excited about this yeah now
Clint I've got a bird here on my
shoulder yeah you've got a Parrot there
in your hand what do you do what is what
is your what are you doing well I've
been in town for over 25 years and at
Night by night I do a show have actually
on the Strip for 25 plus years and I go
I'm gonna move downtown where they're
more Community uh friendly so most
people that come to our show are from
Las Vegas Yes when you're on the Strip
they're out of town okay you never see
them again so now I get to be downtown
then when I go pump gas people going hey
I saw you last night at this show you're
great with the words so I have the
greatest talking singing flying birds in
the world but by day these guys are all
rescues so I have I have a thing called
the birdbus.com
that's how the show's gonna be today a
little
okay what are you doing the Performing
birds do they sing what do they do they
say I have a bird that sings I have
birds of talk I have a bird that was on
AGT considered the greatest free flying
bird in the world and what does this guy
do nothing he does photos he's
Instagram worthy yeah
and this is what we do during the day
and he's looking this way here now hold
on
this is what peaches done
she dances
yeah that's right man check it out so
much
okay there we go we got that one she'll
talk say hello hello hello she does
impersonations do a chicken
hey what do you think about the host of
the show
[Laughter]
a drunken chicken this is half our
audience every night so watch
that's what they look like walking down
Fremont Street
like I said during the day I give people
with my bird it's birdbus.com don't
remember that yeah remember that you can
hold this bird like this when I get done
with him anybody can hold them anyway
they do not know how to bite this is
fantastic yeah and then I get like I
give blind children children autism that
opportunity in life they'll never ever
get so bite night I'm I mean he makes
the drunks laugh yes right and during
the day I make the ones with the needy
that you know have special needs very
happy you're giving back to the
community absolutely where's the
showroom located downstairs it's 5 17
Fremont Street it's the old don't tell
mamas it's absolutely beautiful you will
not have a bad night there even if you
try I love it you guys have so much fun
thank you uh this guy is having a clean
up on the set Rocky what's up